but I don't I'm not high all the time
like I'm not high during the day what
else it just shows and but your
chemistry's probably dude get in here
Joel we got four over here I couldn't in
no gay stuff bro I called it bro okay
stuff just water what's the name of this
podcast if the phone if the phones on
then you know what happens something
funny
[ __ ] phone it may be Johnny Depp
calling them we put Johnny Depp on
speakerphone yeah whether I for one
appreciate exists the only day my
phone's ever been on a voice for
broadcasting there are broadcasting
voices right it's like a sound that a
dude can hit like a Howard Cosell who
like lets you know though how the
[ __ ] game started you know that we're
gonna do the audiobook podcast style so
he can just
alright here find a [ __ ] paragraph or
a chapter or something
just cuz he has such a great voice but
then we can go off topic with the book
yeah that's a great idea that's a great
idea to offer completely original
content along with your book dad that's
a really great I bet that'll be that's a
monster idea because I would love that
as a fan like to listen and on that cuz
I read as bad as bill bird does copy
knows a worse when I go you ever buy a
audiobook with Stephen King reading his
own [ __ ] he has he swallows his elf he's
deaf and I got a glob you want
an actor you want one of those drama
queens or offer your audiobook for like
offer it for like $10 to download
someone's a Bernie Sanders fan then when
you get no when you get to the last
chapter it's like okay you must pay nine
more dollars if you want to hear the end
of the book he's a Trump fan I take it
back dude you find out he's really a
Trump fan like super Trump fan okay what
do you do you're alone with a guy people
are watching it I took one hit of Doug
Stanhope cigarette I understand it I get
it I smoked a hit of Doug Stanhope
cigarette did you get the buzz I got a
heart attack II little thing cigarettes
for ten years just because the first
cigarette I had was so good see man I
got lucky the first cigarette I had it
felt [ __ ] it just felt so stupid it
was just [ __ ] smoke and burning this
weirdness in my lungs wipe - I did I
just quit a few months ago does it feel
weird being right next to Doug I do have
like a douchey e-cigarette in my pocket
because when I start to get drunk
they're only douchey because of those
commercials they [ __ ] up with those
blue commercials where the Stephen Dorff
was like hanging out in black and white
like I have a question because they they
made it was illegal to advertise
cigarettes like in the seventies right
but podcasting is a new generation is
that could we get a camel
good point oh I wonder what the law is
if it's pertains to all commercial
commercial endeavors like like if you
advertise something like but can they so
do ads on Billboard's I don't know I
don't know that stop - right so it used
to be like TV I don't think it's good
that's good I would have moral
compunction about advertising cigarettes
but just because I found a loophole I
would but he won't Marlboro was gonna
give you you know a bunch of money to
just if you said I smoke Marla's gonna
give me mall Barozzi but is do you think
it's probably just all ads cuz have you
ever seen an internet ad for cigarettes
no I don't think I've ever seen the
internet so it can't be that they're
they can't be legal on the internet
because if it was we would we were seen
yes to do a bit you don't have to you
don't see an advertisement for cocaine
because it's word of mouth yeah what if
they drop off like cigarettes on movie
sets you know cuz do you know that they
do that with like TV sets like TV sets
they drop off like coca-cola and
Gatorade and [ __ ] yeah but no but not
just that but I'm saying is they give
you free stuff they give free stuff to
these sets so that you use their stuff
and if you use their stuff then either
people see you with it or you know when
we did the man showed there was a
cigarette company or like a startup
called legit cigarettes they were giving
me free cigarettes for life until they
went out of business as long as I would
smoke those publicly and that was there
that was their gimmick they were gonna
get celebrities celebrities move I
wonder why it didn't pan out
Downey jr.
I did the show later big to fail I did I
did the show you remember when Greg
Kinnear had that show called later yeah
we had a bunch of guest hosts and I
guest hosted at once and I did a segment
with Morton Downey jr. where I was
trying to get Morton Downey jr. to give
me advice unlike how to become a good
talk-show host because he was crazy you
ever ever watch the show was a
documentary so I got to hang with him
like for a day he was one nicest [ __ ]
guys like Morton Downey jr. was super
nice it was all just an act like he he
just figured out a way to rile people up
and do this thing but when you around
him like in real life he's like hey how
are you what's going on man he's like
totally normal like really friendly
really nice [ __ ] when all those
racists tackled him in a airport men's
room there's like parts like he's like
trying to shave my head but do you know
which way it goes off the top of your
head well that's what kind of busted him
they said you could tell he drew it in
the mirror because it was [ __ ]
backward would you know how to do it
forwards I think I don't know looking at
it I probably know you on that yeah but
how do you know it's the wrong but true
Nazis probably wouldn't write it on your
head they're probably just retards what
they're not really they're probably not
even really Nazis he's gonna hold you
down and draw the mark on your face
they're probably just pretending to be
Nazis cuz it's funny but he's pretending
to be kind of well he did he definitely
pretended yeah but but he would be like
Nazis would love him like why would
maybes do that to him yeah I was a
minute.what Nazi do that to Trump I
would say I would say it's two steps
removed because I said the most likely
scenario would be someone holding him
down to pretending they're not see
because they think it would be funny to
write on Morton Downey Juju's head yeah
so I give that if it really happen is
here but but I don't think it really did
happen
so then it's like if you had to do a
Nazi swastika on your head would you get
it right
like you're looking in the mirror would
you okay is it like this or is it like
this which [ __ ] way does it go I mean
was anybody know I can smart first for
smartphones you couldn't Google it
what's crazy is like now that symbol
swastika that swastika symbol was an
ancient karate symbol it was an ancient
Okinawan karate symbol like it was a
part of like ancient Eastern like sacred
geometry like this this little thing the
swastika thing yeah whatever it meant
originally some temple that has it in
West Hills yeah there's a big science in
Indian people go there and get married
it's this beautiful place now notice can
you announce who's at the table no one
cares we write we write down on the
internet what it
chad shank just informed us that chi
gong has a swastika in this down a bit
so we're not all talking over each other
you know the way to cure that chad shank
is my co-host on my podcast i'm gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of you in front of
your right it was really i thought it
was a clear joke this is the Comedy
Store podcast if if anyone is wondering
what's going on right now we are in our
new studio in the basement the stove
Ching never been down here carpet on the
walls you heard a lot of people died in
this basement it's one of the haunted
areas of the couch
rick ingram may I ask you sir because
you have been a resident of this fine
establishment for many many a moon have
you [ __ ] seen anything have you ever
seen it ghost have you ever have seen
any inclination I I've never seen a
ghost I got really high in the belly
room one time
and there was like three of us we're all
sitting in there the lights were out and
basically just the emergency light was
on mm-hmm and we were pretty positive
like all of us turned at the same time
because it seemed like someone was
walking in the hallway from the belly
room to the green room and there was
nothing there
and then we all just got real freaked
out like we got to leave but we were
also really high so that's true but I've
been really high all over this place and
the belly room freaks me the [ __ ] out
the creepiest dude I've been up there a
couple of times in the last six months I
go up there with a friend
come on dude let's go in the belly room
know what there's no show and you go up
to the top of the stairs just stand
there and look at that place you go what
the [ __ ] are we doing here we got to get
out of here I saw Joe Rogan what last
week yeah doing some goofy show where
people yell out topics and you have to
riff and [ __ ] Rogan killed it
termite Watkins oh that room is so ripe
to do specials to film specials yeah
yeah I feel [ __ ] hate specials that
are filmed in theaters and the applause
just like Jim Norton
I saw a Jim Norton special in a 1500
seater and you know how Norton ribs yeah
and you know the audience is ruining his
special you're [ __ ] ruining his
rhythm well I think you're making a real
good point that we make all the time
that this this point that this is a
giant difference I mean you know you
know I've had about a hundred
conversations about this between your
rhythm that you do in a little intimate
environment and the rhythm that you do
in a big theater because in like 150
people you can just keep hammering him
with punchlines and they can hear
everything you're saying well one of the
things that I realized by sitting in the
audience of a Louis black show I was in
Jersey and he was there the night before
I was so Joey Diaz and I walked across
the street and we sat down we act sat in
the audience and watched a show like
tour in the back towards the middle so
we had like good seats we were right in
there but I was like whoa it is hard to
hear when he's when he's killing and
everyone's laughing and then he says
something else well if you see if you
say something wild people laugh you know
people just started going what did he
say what did you say there's no going
but people were laughing that heard it
but it was like you might miss a
percentage of the audience Thanks you
know you should get those you you know
when you go to a museum they give you
Twitter's I think we already did this a
couple of times yeah we'll clear it all
up in editing that's we just did the
very beginning before the swastika
discussion that we found a Comedy Store
promise oh hi I forgot what we're
talking about what was so important
while we're talking about it what is the
number what is the number where it gets
weird because 50 because I'm like all
right they there must be a mix-up why
are there this many people here to see
me did they put house Sparks on the
calendar on accident better screech from
Saved by the Bell
crushing house parks is better because
it's utterly ruthless he was there the
night after I did the ice house I
remember probably sparks back when I
used to actually have to do my own
fulfillment of merch from my website
house parks bought my CD wow he's a nice
guy early days very nice guy well here's
my question about filming in the belly
room so you film in a room that small it
would be awesome but with cameras and
crew in there how many how many people
well I was talking to Jesse a cameraman
in a mirror oh so true
that's dramas [ __ ] Jeselnik was telling
me today about how he filmed his Netflix
special at the Fillmore theater in San
Francisco which is pretty small it's
only like 450 people but he filmed it
with mounted stuff to the walls and
people had like remote controls no no so
with that you could easily do that in
the belly room he set something up above
the crowd in a couple spots and you
would get you only really want to head
on and his sideways so wrong
flying around fly over crowd shot shaped
like a dick like a bumblebee what is it
that would add to the show to makes
noise - [ __ ] they're gonna let me film a
special in the main room
they are whose day these powers that be
the Dark Lord's Baltimore Baltimore but
I got they got me on camera - or you
[ __ ] I don't know how to do it Brandon
Wallace gets shot up in Texas America's
haters I do a lot of crowd work so I
don't know I'm trying to figure out how
to do it to where I can get shot to the
crowd but a wall-mount might be the only
way without work this crowd man ask me
what I do
you've always preferred that you've
always preferred that [ __ ] around
with the crowd thing it's interesting it
made one the jokes I used to tell
weren't good so when I started doing
crowd or it was just like I know I'm
funnier than this from kids I know I'm
greater than my act that's a good aren't
we all everybody [ __ ] yeah I am yeah but
for it for you like importantly like
there's a lot of people that got really
[ __ ] weird about having to follow you
yeah there's a giant issue with people
it's like there's there's a certain
segment of our community that gets upset
when someone's doing good you don't like
it and if you're doing good in some
method that is different than the way
I'm doing it then somehow another I have
this this right I'm gonna stool like
Dane Cook tonight but it was funny kind
of [ __ ] bro he was first of all I
[ __ ] it first but but what you were
what you're doing like there's a well
you didn't have any power man and it was
really [ __ ] up because there was a
bunch of dudes who this is from my
perspective there's a bunch of dudes who
didn't want to follow Rick Ingraham
because Rick Ingram would [ __ ] around
with the crowd and he's he's got so much
material on top of [ __ ] around the
crowd and you do it all the time so it's
a muscle that you have like really
exercised
yeah so there's a bunch of Hemery
[ __ ] he was a bud buzz a bunch of
[ __ ] because you weren't doing
anything wrong you were doing really
funny comedy boring shows what the other
comics are made of though like I would
rather go up after a fight like if
somebody's killing and they're awful and
hacky then you're like what that's a
horrible idea
yeah and it's like a feeling well
they're not gonna like me if they like
this Doug Stanhope tell the story about
the old Hedberg days or Hedberg people
used to put these middle acts on in
front of Hedberg that would do [ __ ]
somersault there would you fire crackers
out of their ass they would sing R&B
songs they would have these big
high-energy middle acts and then Hedberg
would go on after him before people knew
who he was
that's and they didn't know how to
adjust it was just shitty planning it's
shitty filming yeah I know that story
you you know how you got into it I just
move on I thought about it now I thought
about the actual story anyway yeah you
know it's a point point being you got is
two ways there's two ways to look at it
like in one way like a guy like Hedberg
has to be shielded in a way like he's so
goddamn good it's almost like listen you
got to find out how good he is everybody
just get on board once I find out how
good he is it doesn't matter who goes on
before I don't do like mixed bill shows
hey you want to do a set tonight no I
don't I want to do a set in front of my
crowd where I know that they're gonna
accept everything I don't want to
[ __ ] deal with tourist [ __ ] I don't I
don't like doing comedy that much I
totally hear what you're saying spent 25
years building my crowd I'm not gonna go
up and ruin all my self-confidence by
going up on a Saturday night at the
Comedy Store to do ten minutes where if
I have a bit it's 15 minutes long right
right I'm gonna try to truncate it dude
well listen I got news for you dude well
you
the marquee people are gonna be your
fans are gonna show up I mean they're
gonna be your fancy I'm making a [ __ ]
a lot of money
but you don't have to look this is the
thing about this place like that
[ __ ] all the time no no no no no no I
this is trashing you on sanitation I do
like to do honesty I think you lasted
like six weeks no crash a car I can't
see Joanna Mountain being alive if he's
not within 15 minutes of a comedy no no
that was one of the reasons why I moved
to Colorado is because the Comedy Works
in Denver yeah wendy has like this full
open mic a little mountains the point is
you like to do comedy Rogen's moving
back from Colorado because coyotes ate
his dog nose it was a mountain lion the
mountain like we found a mountain lion
on our property and it started started
creeping around the house can't live
without doing comedy I love not doing
come III I could totally see your point
of view and I could totally fall into
that too it's not that I only love doing
comedy I love doing a lot of [ __ ] it's
just I've been doing comedy for so long
I decide to give it a lot of love you
like but like I would I might just like
to go camping
how about that I might just like to take
a Toyota [ __ ] abandoned comedy or die
in a hotel like George Carlin that might
be the move to
wait I don't know what the [ __ ] up Tonya
Harding I just say I will hold on I know
the only non paid regular is Brendan no
he's doing a drop-in I sighs Twitter but
when you showcase here was that you in
the beginning building your audience
what is this a real [ __ ] interview
all of a sudden how dare you Eleanor
what when I showcased er I I had my my
favorite bit I've ever written it was
about TWA flight 800 we're talking funny
already down by a missile
I honestly to this day there was a
[ __ ] hot waitress at the improv that
said she came out I was sitting at the
bar back to the old improv and she came
out bitching about the [ __ ] hackneyed
comedy she's listening which I was on
her side and flight 800 was on the TV at
the bar she goes yeah make that funny ha
ha ha I went home and I wrote a [ __ ]
one of the best bits I didn't deliver it
as well cuz I was young but a the my
favorite bit I've ever written was about
that and so you did it so I had that hip
pocketed I'd never had the balls to come
here and I came here and Mitzie back
when she was alive
no no she's still alive weekend at
Bernie's away bro we're in her house
miss Beckett I did that bit because I
was when you had to go as your dad well
you can google it as when was the point
when three weeks as like because it was
right before that I like
yes remembers there was another plane
right after flight 800 value jet that
crashed into the Florida swamps in
Florida and they never [ __ ] got it
out because there's too many alligators
you know do you know how not only does
your plane crash but it crashes into a
swamp full of alligators
David hell bit my favorite plane crash
and I know it's wrong to have a favorite
the coast of Colombia and it said some
of the survivors were eaten by sharks
how bad is your luck where the two
weirdest so [ __ ] funny Eleanor do you
remember the Paul Mooney bit about
valujet doing Paul Mooney I'd used to do
this bit about black lady clutching her
purse remember he's just bit about some
about how cheap valujet was and that you
knew it was gonna crash you knew that
[ __ ] was gonna crash eventually he oh my
god Mooney had some hilarious [ __ ] about
that
we get eaten by crocodiles really Paul
Mooney brought it to a racial place
clear up I didn't see a cup no it was a
funny bit I remember laughing really
hard he intimidated the [ __ ] out of me
oh yeah one of the only people Eddie
Griffin would respect oh yeah reverend
al sharpton of comedy no no no he's way
more respected referred to me as the
white lady you would worry Lou oh is the
white lady the white lady's gonna cash
my check make sure you tell the white
lady I'm coming in well the white lady
isn't like
but you're all white like that you're
not cool Hennigan my manager this filthy
Scotsman here taking pictures every time
we're on the road he likes to ask the
waitstaff like who's the worst comic
you've had to deal with and Eddie
Griffin is always in the top three yeah
he needs to get a carton of smokes and a
new sneakers at every show right that's
what the Improv people calling car any
waited I can oh [ __ ] a white car well
you know have some respect
okay how about bring him a [ __ ] black
car you expect him to get in a white car
we're talking about it how about you
think about using uber
top three of all time I mean as he used
to say he got into Harvard and Yale but
he chose to drop out of very offended
that's what he claims to know this I'm
standing up for Eddie Griffin right now
you don't know [ __ ] you don't know
nothing about him
you're scared of them I'm scared of his
talent let me tell you something real
Eddie Griffin when he was on chat shank
when he was on def Comedy Jam Eddie
Griffin did a set on def Comedy Jam
wearing shorts I mean he crushed he
crushed so hard that I'm ever sitting
there was an open micro at the time I
was like oh my god when you see a guy
who crushes that hard it makes you feel
like I'm never gonna do that I'm never
gonna do that I'm never gonna do that he
had a high hat on he had shorts on and
he [ __ ] destroyed if Eddie Murphy if
Eddie Griffin rather could have stayed
on track he just looked ridiculous but
I'm telling you that [ __ ] dude had
Talent
crazy it was insane but he had talent
that in its best form when he could hold
on to it he was like a wrestling match
with a [ __ ] steroid dolphin it's like
you barely got it Wow because we are in
the business at what point
do you go well that guy's a dick he's
not a dick
Eddie's crazy he's not he's not a bad
guy he's always been good to me me and
him have always been cool
I only just like steve Schirripa what
steve Schirripa liked you
yeah yeah no but Steve well he's not a
dick
he's just if you get out of line he's
the wrong guy he's the wrong guy he will
smack you in your [ __ ] head it
doesn't matter who's bit of a soprano
Laurette but not ya Trevor smacked you
in the face smacked me in the face funny
you doing seven minutes not 7:01 not 699
I get along with those dudes the Riviera
is like a lot of people's first Vegas
game good for them nice first 9/11 and
then that Joey Diaz got banned when will
Steve Joey Diaz got banned for a little
bit yeah you got a ban for something on
remember what happened but uh sure Ripa
like that guy kept that gig he was a
he's a savage he's a savage a bona fide
legitimate savage is trying to keep it
together in E pizza is he's a gorilla
and he'll crush your head with a rock
how many shows he's been on he will get
out he'll go knee to chest on you and
smash your [ __ ] head with a bowling
ball and there's not a goddamn thing you
gotta do about it either he's is that's
a real legit gorilla it's a great guy
though I feel about Eddie Griffin did he
like him did did Griffin perform at the
Riviera I don't I don't know if he did I
don't know if he did I only knew Eddie
Griffin in the he was already really
crazy right go up like what you did you
get here
I got here in 2002 yeah so Eddie was at
his best in the 90s yeah this guy just
basically have breakdowns on stage he
would steal champagne out of like you
distract the manager and that have his
entourage steal champagne allegedly say
allegedly at the very least could be
sued once you have enough money to be
sued you go away allegedly sir well how
like hitting Katt Williams seem to have
had the same career
how about Martin Lawrence this is Martin
Lawrence yeah like so don't you think
there might be something to that
Illuminati professors like theory of
okay here's the mo K here's the most we
have to not talk over each other yeah
podcasted [ __ ] the most likely scenario
is someone who's really funny is someone
who's a little imbalance so they seek
attention in a very extreme way they
figure out how to get really good at
making people love them because people
don't love them enough when they're
young so they get to a certain stage and
then all sudden people are loving them
and not just loving them they're loving
them and mass all throughout the world
they can't go anywhere they're praised
too much and they start to freak the
[ __ ] out all right now the roller
coaster Brendon was saying what Laurence
and Martin Lawrence and then they have
professor Griff from Public Enemy but he
went different he went right he got
radicalized but he's all guy and you
even hear from like Chappelle on Inside
the Actors Studio where it's like young
black when young black guys get
successful they're targeted by somebody
I could see how he would think that I
could see how he would think it's way
more likely it's it's way more likely
that there's no profit to be made by
holding them back and more more ever
there's more profit to be made by
propping them up I doubt highly doubt
that someone's gonna spend money to try
to tank them I think quite the opposite
they'd spend money to medicate them to
prop
get them shrinks to get them a hand but
they're not gonna make driver though
like if they're not here's the thing
that's a prop that's it wants to talk or
what you do is you go Joe has a good
point and then Joe shuts the [ __ ] up
because ego
oh he's gonna point I just wanted to get
it out try very hard Joe a drink uniform
keep them out there sorry
Doug is yelling at his manager nod I was
also I was also saying that like 90% for
comedic effect sir Griff was right but
you would never think that the
government is really trying to sabotage
young black eyes systematically or
whatever I mean I would think that if
there is somebody who could really
change the world the government would
like maybe John Lennon was shot by
somebody did you see season three of
Martin I don't know I was like in high
school
right powerful message of imagination
but Katt Williams went really crazy
because now he's basically fighting high
school kids he's the guy who's getting
knocked out by high school kids on
YouTube well it's just your disparaging
cat's name chill it's back up here and
you saw them even get choked out he got
outwrestled that's all and I'm pretty
sure it was a junior high the kid is 15
allegedly someone said 17 some sense a
lie is actually 17 either way it's a
tough fall either way of a 17-year old
[ __ ] you up for rank is crossing it why
is a 17 year old and you in a fight yeah
why are you in that situation
why are you
Highschool Katt Williams but yes I think
he was at the projects and this kid was
a high school wrestler it was a school
thing yeah it was a charity
I don't even research it at all and
argue now we're just a bunch of [ __ ]
gossiping while I was saying nah dude I
think is it the project I didn't I might
have seen something on someone else's
computer
Kathleen's fight I had watch the Twitter
link down against the wall no no no I
stay away from teenagers by law yeah III
won fight it's a long story
she won't go what was an improv Carrigan
just hero we see how my nose is caved in
on this side that was a Tempe improv
waiter oh and I deserved it I
he punched in that really yeah but I was
asking for it would you do he said with
my girlfriend in front of him as they
drop me off at the condo I thought she
might want to [ __ ] me hmm I I think it's
funny that you think getting punched in
the head is being in a fight head-butted
the guy first
no I also think it's funny that he he
said it's a long story and that was by
far the most direct short story you were
really good editor dude your stories are
[ __ ] awesome
I had that last day I got beat up in
Alaska new story let's figure out what
the [ __ ] happened over here folks Jesus
Christ
Douglas why this why did you why were
you convinced that thank you why were
you convinced that it was gonna happen
with you and the girl maybe she was
sending some weird signals because she
likes fights no she
was sending weird signals like if I [ __ ]
you would you tell tell stories in the
morning we were at some 80s [ __ ]
dance after so [ __ ] long she's at
rabble it's it she's a dirty girl
this is 1995 no my dirty girls a girl at
a show in Anchorage Alaska and she she
came to our shores they were a threat is
easy and she's like hey we should get
out of here I'm just like yeah this is
great
she's like let's stop at this other bar
first then we'll go I'm like okay we
walk in the other bar and immediately
just see 3 or 4 dudes much larger than
myself
I'll get up and I was like oh this is
first of all are these black guys
because the way countenance 3/4 guys now
they're white dudes they were they were
snowmobilers and one of them was the
boyfriend of the girl I was with of
course
he very clearly was just trying to get a
fight going mmm and security broke us up
security is like real hardcore there or
it's like if you get in a fight at a bar
then you get banned from going to bars
fluckey yeah cuz dudes have whaling
knives on the foot belts to fight he
escorted me to the back door and they
were pushing the other guys towards the
front door and he took me the back and
he open the door and he said I can't do
anything once you're outside of the bar
so if I were you I would run I just
walked out January so covered in snow
and ice and I was running like the
four-minute mile and was anybody behind
you running after you
no cuz they would have had to go all the
way around the buildings so they didn't
know you were running away I mean they
probably assumed one of these guys
that's so scary alone but the problem is
it's like they feel like especially when
they're drunk
that they have the right to do that
because I will show but they're like how
the [ __ ] could you have known
you know yeah I'm literally thinking she
just wants to do another drink to think
I'm a little more trying how does how
does it you see I put it on the guy how
many drinks
guy should know a guy should know what
kind of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] he's dating
if she does [ __ ] like that and if you
know that that's what you're doing
you're hanging out with the girls that
[ __ ] crazy then it's supposed to be
on what you might like it to like am I
like fighting and it's like you might be
just too dumb I'm going interest like
that they send out I've been in a
fuckload of drunken fights and you guys
are way over analyzing the drunken
fights it's not a lot of logic involved
I can't even watch children's cartoons
without finding the hitting meaning I
mean I got like kind of beat up in
Alaska but it was well it was this is I
mean I got my ass kicked in Philly a
bunch of times but tell the story but
don't let me forget to tell the yours
Sioux Falls South Dakota story Anchorage
tell your [ __ ] Anchorage get to do yeah
all right so angry low dance was yeah I
tried to dance I was funny dancing in
Sioux Falls we could probably do one
night show he's done the week and I'm
doing a Sunday or something yeah so he
he comes in and tells me about Saturday
I'm doing this Sunday Saturday night you
go out after with the staff a dance club
in Sioux Falls which is a real [ __ ] well
you might have to refresh me I mean I
remember the ins and outs like we go and
I was funny dancing on the okay yes I
made yeah you gotta define that dude he
didn't
I could do the dance for you but it yes
there's a lot of clapping under the legs
and saluting your hand behind your back
like you're on the family feud fast
fingers talks to some townie girl and
says hey do you want to slow dance yeah
and she goes she insult she was really
mean to me she was like I'd rather kill
myself yeah you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you [ __ ] that means she likes you
dude well what he didn't take it like
that you know what you gonna pretend
like you're gonna Maya pine a beer in my
hand
totally movie and it hit it hit other
people
Senna's big lake you know falls type of
fellow Sioux Falls type of guy gets up
in my face and it's nothing he says
something like you just threw a drink in
a girl's face or whatever and I said
yeah chivalry and he like gets up like
it was a fight and I go hey jokingly hey
do you want to slow dance he made a joke
that she didn't get and she [ __ ] and
so it was a bad
in hindsight it was you know I'm like
well girls throw drinks and guys faces
and movies all the time
on a podcast if we're all equal in this
society Jess you know listen it was a
split section latest split second like
what's the funniest right okay I have
most of a beer sploosh hits a guy and
then he gets up and gets in my face and
I said don't bow up on me you [ __ ]
hayseed and I just got grabbed by I mean
I didn't get all the staff drags him out
you're gonna get killed this town were
you hammered yeah of course
I'd be able to do that as like a sober
person I heard this I heard this story
the next morning when I came into play
this Sunday and he was a so reticent and
as like I shouldn't have done that I
can't fight is that morning after shame
he wasn't celebrating this story well
the other kids that were with me were
just kind of like Jesus thank God we got
out of there like you know put other
people in jeopardy with my antics Gino's
like that who was like that when he's
younger is Bobby Lee Bobby Lee almost
got got us killed in a strip club in San
Diego in like 1996 we were down there
we're doing La Jolla we're doing La
Jolla Comedy Store and I met Bobby Lee
and he was like just starting out he was
like working he was working there he was
working there and so we went to this
strip club and there were these real
legit gangbangers with long silky combed
hair I mean long hair they like went
down to their pockets right and whose do
that tattoos on his face and he was
talking to this girl and Bobby Lee he's
like ooh that girl's really pretty I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go [ __ ] hit on her
and he goes over this girl while she's
with all these gangbangers and
apparently one of these gangbangers was
the boyfriend of this girl so he stood
up and I looked at him and I looked at
Bobby and there's a feeling that you get
when you know someone either has killed
someone
or is ready to kill someone or thought
about killing someone hey there's some
people with tattoos in their face and
the 90s yeah and those people were scary
[ __ ] people it's not like rappers
today and white guys have tattoos all
over the place in their face try to fit
in this is a rare thing and I and I
jumped up and I think I don't forget who
was with me but I go we're going we're
going right now and Bobby Lee is like
where the [ __ ] you guys going just relax
guys are [ __ ] I go [ __ ] you I go
we're getting out of here right now and
I and I grabbed everybody and I ran I
ran to my car in the parking lot and
jumped in and as we're pulling away they
though the door opened and these guys
stepped out and Bobby Lee those guys are
[ __ ] so we're gonna do [ __ ] I believe
guts you ever hears he got straight
crazy for a while yeah his mind
I call this Joe Rogan syndrome where if
you're around Joe Rogan you have a lot
of something feels like six seven and
just jacked this is like I was running
late he was like six to seven years old
we do the opposite in Bisbee with Chad
shank like Chad shank always wants Chad
Easy's labeling you right now is
defining you I didn't know fight stories
were fun I got like 40 of them if we
want to talk him out of podcast whenever
we get home I thought they were boring
to everybody else who listen as well the
rest of us aren't apparently fighting
for real because all of our fight
stories look on your faces like what
what are we talking about it's like now
this was like a really well produced
show all they would splice in the music
to everybody was kung foo if you give
this to Jay Lee he will over produce it
you guys have the best produced podcast
because it just starts you know and
that's really I should probably start
mine just starting like no Doug's not
you're like halfway through here you
okay Doug's like is it is on and then
you guys just roll turn it on and then
someone's like are we going to Mike yeah
yeah we've been going we can can I ask
you a question sure it all you years the
Comedy Store don't you feel like this is
a weird time like this this place is
very very bizarre because I spent a
decade here basically alone in terms of
like the crowd is like would max out at
like 70 on like a great weekend night
there's a lot of times I did main room
shows where there's like 40 people in
there and now it's basically sold out
every weekend and it's like we're saying
yeah talking to Marc Maron earlier and
it's like the crowds here are great now
but it's impossible to find somewhere to
hang out with just a thousand people
running into you out on the patio well
that's why the comic bar is the best
it's grey little backstage bar is and
Kerri Mitchell and Mitchell Carrie
Mitchell came out here I go the only
place that you should be working
she's as a drunk the only person that
you give any credit to your bartender is
the most important person and she is the
best bartender and this is the bar and
she actually got a [ __ ] job here and
it's vent and she got accepted like that
immediately because she's so legit she's
so legit everybody went oh okay come on
in it's like give your [ __ ] hey hire
this guy you're very specific when you
give your word on a comic hunter percent
yeah bartender I'm the same way Carrie
Mitchell asked for bind up when you come
to the comedy yeah well she got the
instant Doug Stanhope ass cuz she told
me she was friends with you but then she
was just so cool I was like
is so nice she's so nice side-splitter
No
well I'll tell you what man the staff
here has always been awesome it's always
been on sorry the staff here has always
been like it's far like the staff here
other than Tommy the staff here has
always been [ __ ] amazing
yeah always fit in anywhere they're what
we fit in there were the dead years and
this is a Bisbee reference where Bisbee
has where I live in Arizona they have
the ghost tour because they have nothing
else to offer and that's the dead years
of the Comedy Store is when oh there's
it's haunted well there was a period
like when I got here in 94 from like 94
out of 98 it was dark
oh it was it was no work the main the
main room was never open it was never
open it was it was there was a comedy
boom in the 80s and something happened
in the 90s or dropped it dropped off so
hard at the store I don't know what it
was and it mighta corresponding with
Mitzi's health decline it might have
been there if anybody's looking to buy a
new car how magical is in the house how
rude he's got a guy I will [ __ ] I've
always said this and I've said this now
too
okay and I have to piss real soon
yeah yeah I have to take a leak but but
that wasn't it that wasn't a slam on our
it's no I've said if I will return your
call if you if you call out about a show
business thing if you have somebody calm
like you can do a test have somebody
call out like hey I have this show that
I want you to do a part on and then you
call them and say hey I need a new deck
built in my backyard he'll call the deck
guy back first because al loves to
[ __ ] hook people up with a guy to
build a deck or help you I'm the guy
who's got a guy is that that's an
important part of Kumari I really enjoy
finding I fix people's like problems
under 10,000 Rogan Chad shank Brett
Brendon Walsh al Madrigal and Nancy
Kerrigan those that signing off you're
saying we can do whatever the [ __ ] we
want we don't have to do seven minutes
if you keep this thing going we could
but why not why does everybody want to
make these things an hour
yeah any time like we just wandered down
here I've never even been in this
basement before scared we going oh I'm
taking a mic I feel altered now we have
less people talking over each other like
when you're close to me now I can look
now I lose your head is bloated from
human growth hormones mine is blaster
own I think mostly either way mines
mines out all yours is it's also like
lifting heavy [ __ ] there's something
about I do it a lot yeah
it's not that bad what it does is that
you get used to it so if you do it like
three or four days in a row after a
while your body gets accustomed to it
produce norepinephrine which is a an
Oracle neuro chemical that makes you
happy it also reduces inflammation like
your inflammatory bodies in the blood or
reduces all that [ __ ] isn't that
redundant since you already smoke weed
no no it's not it's it's on this
molecular level apparently what happens
is your body freaks the [ __ ] out because
things gonna die because you're in this
250 degree below zero tank you walk into
this room and you shut the door and it's
like a like a like a freezer and you're
standing there it's 250 degrees below
zero and you do it for three minutes and
when you do it your body produces what's
called cold shock proteins and cold
shock proteins attack inflammation it's
literally like your body starts shutting
down it freaks out and it so it mass
produces this like panic hormone and
these growth shock proteins and all this
stuff accelerates like tissue healing in
the body and it makes you feel better
like you got like literally you like
your mind feels better when you get out
of there Joe told me he told me to take
a vitamin D and I did that because I was
tired in the afternoon I changed your
life more than 75% of Americans are
deficient in vitamin D because we're not
outside that's one of the ways your body
produces it but another way your body
produces animal proteins but you can get
in a supplement form and it's very
important or you get moved to Bisbee
Arizona or out in the Sun all the time
less you're a [ __ ] mole you like to
go deep deep deep deep on the ground New
York City I was there it like you don't
see the Sun at all right New York City
their greatest [ __ ] every what you
would imagine as a writer the there
there gray hunched people how could you
live in that [ __ ] awful place you
know what it is it has an attachment of
Romanticism to it so when you move to a
place like that or if you move to Paris
it is but it isn't see if you believe in
it that it is but you're too smart for
it so it isn't it's like placebos and
like faith healers like they can work
but you got to believe in them but the
[ __ ] catch-22 is you're too [ __ ]
smart to believe in them so they'll
never work like stealing religion
clothes yeah it's in the it's in the
ballpark if you believe in it it works
but yeah no Sun and yeah it's [ __ ]
it's a good place to hang out if you
have like billions of dollars you're
fly-in you're staying a penthouse
apartment then you jet or how do we get
Chad shank in a comedy that's what I
wanted to thanks already in comedy he's
here right now I know are you Doug
handler who's calling hang on Lynn
shawcroft is on the Comedy Store podcast
live on speakerphone we're in the
basement you called me Brian Hennigan is
coming to get you just just be by the
back toilets by the o.r toe the
established rule is no geisha or smoking
in the basement you just look for
Hannigan by chakra is so [ __ ] funny
as a person she's a [ __ ] nightmare
right I was on the road with Shaylee and
Mitch and Linn and they would lose
everything constantly standing there and
she walks up and I was explaining to
other people how they kept losing stuff
and she walked up and she goes we can't
find the can
all right so just on cue like if
somebody cuter and then she walked away
and then came back and she goes we also
lost the RV that was chaley driving the
RV sleep anymore [ __ ] so yeah I guess
this podcast will go on no [ __ ] shot
crops coming down yeah she's coming down
we will we will cross for the listener
Mitch Hedberg if you don't know Mitch
Hedberg first of all you're an [ __ ]
don't say second of all is because some
she is laksa days ago about putting out
his lifework let's not give a [ __ ] about
that no yeah you could do that privately
I do yeah well it's not she's on here so
we're just talking [ __ ] about everyone
her bag that's she currently dates John
Doerr who's one of the funny who she's
[ __ ] after Mitch's rest his peace
last week I was talking to you I don't
know Brendon Walsh who doesn't get sets
here for some reason even though he's
the most brilliant [ __ ] guy I know he
went up that night we were talking in
the parking lot
you got a move here there's a new scene
you're [ __ ] all over me what I didn't
know at that time he went up while we're
talking in the parking lot me and Joe
Rogan's he went up as John doar yeah did
a set doing John Dorsey so silly I start
taking he's just crazy
Brendan's crazy he's [ __ ] great but
he's really funny
he's really fun he's really funny he's
really smart but like when he's talking
about the the thing about throwing that
beer in the girl's face like he has this
impulsiveness to him that he almost
doesn't know how to how to wrap up all
the time he really I mean he's done some
of the best pranks like in the Silver
Lake gun store and he there was a are
BJ's and he went and bought a he bought
a huge banner and always told us coming
soon it's gonna be Silver Lake Silver
Lake if you don't know is this community
in Los Angeles very like liberal
pretentious like just you know whole
foods they're protesting because it's a
Whole Foods 365 which is a discounted
Whole Foods and the people in that
neighborhood are protesting and saying
that we can afford the real one there
was a cell phone billboard on i-10 for
whatever cell company and there's a
picture of a cell phone on the thing
Brendon Walsh figures out the the the
measurements goes up in the middle of
the night has basically a fat head of
because it's a cell phone but it's blank
in that so he puts the text message in
the cell phone on the billboard saying
your father passed away and the reply
oMG he crawled up he made this [ __ ] my
favorite one was an early one it was a
top chef DC and it was every
he's standing in the arcade and took a
picture and got like a fat head made at
Kinkos of themself with a little chef
outfit with a pot and a spoon just
stirring it up but he didn't get the
measurements just right so the guy was
really miniature he's the size they have
the America's Top Chef and all the
contestants ten contestants so he gets a
Fathead like 1/8 of the size goes up
whittling shawcroft is coming risking
his life like risking his life above
this [ __ ] 7-eleven guys it's not easy
to climb up on those he's a really ok
climbs barbed wire to put himself aside
the other contestants he's so crazy
here's another one that he did this suit
here's one they did that super subtle he
put up a sign for Whole Foods coming
soon in Los Feliz yeah and everybody
went crazy they all went crazy they were
honky when he was putting it up like
yeah giving them they were so excited
it was so excited and it wasn't real he
just thought it'd be funny to [ __ ] with
these people because they wanted a whole
roll in real life he came to Bisbee
unlike Joe Rogan yeah Joe's 20 after he
Brendon Walsh came to Bisbee and he put
up signs all over my neighborhood in a
residential area and it was a hand-drawn
sign that said lost comb lost and it was
a hand-drawn home with teeth missing
this is my comb I lost it I I need it I
use it to comb my hair if you've seen
this comb he just walked around stapling
it to telephone poles around my house
posters or images of the
we were just talking about when you
helped him put up the the America's Top
Chef Brendon Walsh you were yes you
helped John doar went up like on levels
of buildings and I saw them walking
across Lin shawcroft
high I don't know you I'm Eleanor Kevin
al-anon my name is Lynn no middle name
chakra nice um how do you go Chad shank
no I'm I'm catching I know why are you
leaving yeah oh you sure you don't want
to talk about that vice interview we
both did
uh oh it was good they were in my home
as usual I have no one to protect me I
gave him [ __ ] a pair of Mitch's
underwear a [ __ ] chip-chop
interview over yeah I like you jack wait
can I ask more about that by Alan before
Ali please know this mom's got some coin
he's got how we're not all talking over
each other okay
you should put if you're delivering I'll
take another oh you're on the podcast
Carrie Mitchell excited to introduce you
we were just when you move to town I go
there's only one place for you because
you're a bartender is your best friend
and you are the best bartender I've ever
known
where alliteration is a hot mess all
right here I know you're around of
delights I'll give you my new credit
cards that I just got two days ago and
now because you lost your last one it's
not like yeah Jack Koch is fine
we were just talking about you saying
oh we lost our camera oh and we also
lost our RV did you it's not quite like
losing the RV it's like whoa where do we
put it and it seems like I was the
precedent yeah on paper it doesn't seem
like you wouldn't know where your RV is
but put that paper on like a Tuesday's
flip back to a Thursday you can lose the
[ __ ] motorhome and drop a bunch of
blood or a van they left at Phoenix
Airport we left a van because we lived
in the mountains we had to fly out of
Ontario California rather than at LAX
and we fly it up Ontario there's not a
lot of non stops there's lay overs and
the layover were always Phoenix so we
had our van there going on five months
yeah because we drove to a gig there and
then we didn't have time to like drive
it back so it was there and we'd like go
in and tuck in there and be like is
there any drugs in here oh I remember
this let's have a nap then we had to
take the van out and I was like Mitch
just tell them we were there for two
weeks and Mitch was like since when did
we have to live oh so we told them four
months which was a lie
and the lady goes goddamn thank you for
being honest we didn't have your chip
and so like I don't know if you ever
seen a face meltdown and complete
depression it was me and like Mitch just
paid it was like over
three thousand dollars which he only
paid two thousand but those are the
things that get me wait you know I
thought that van was still there after
Mitch died well we got back in the same
place you know we we bought we bought it
out as different same van same airport
different circumstance by women died it
was still there and they called Mitch's
parents and they're like he's dead and
they got rid of it
meanwhile there was like so many
pictures and videos and we made
Christmas cards with a black baby look
they didn't clean it out for you I don't
know because the number attached to it
went to Mitch's parents I think they
were so grief struck and I just told
this story sorry and I didn't remember
it but Lyn shawcroft Justine Bateman
Justine Bateman I just had to tell his
story because someone brought it up oh
you put on your neck CD my book tour
digging up mother
buy it on Amazon yes there you go you
might hear that more than once along the
players bought it yesterday it's so good
so so Shaw Croft is on a no-carb diet so
chubby I was trying to get back in the
game beer okay and Justine Bateman comes
to this show Garrett Morris had a club
downtown
came to that show who loved you at that
point is the guy who came up in humble
brag humble brag guy who wrote a diet
yeah yes you would know anyway continue
on thank you very much ma'am thank you
so she's drinking shawcroft is drinking
vodka at the same rate she would drink
beer so she's hammered there's a
we do a show it's like 10:30 at night
bingo is drinking bingos here - they
show up I have to meet Justine Bateman
and I'm I'm starstruck but yeah this is
just at the beginning when like doors
coming that shank being here in LA
you're like you're like Mallory's zero
so let's go back to the story being I'm
trying to be like your guy and and the
two of these [ __ ] drunken [ __ ] come
down spread in the word it's Justine
Bateman and some producer who produced
Last Comic Standing that I did the
[ __ ] the the presentation pilot for
do you remember me no you're a suit I
don't but I'm trying to be polite and
they come down just recklessly [ __ ] up
at 10:30 at night no we came to both
shows but because it wasn't beer I was
getting vodka and because I was lashing
out with you like diet coke because yeah
I was just drinking blood she's spilling
lis drunk at some point they have the
pizza you know how that I can tell you
what I know I put the pizza on a like
with the fire underneath a little stir
she knocks it over there leftover pizza
and then she's crawling on the floor
after the show pizza and and Justine
Bateman was great she's like taking it
and just flicking her [ __ ] cuz she knows
they're too drunk to rhyme stand by the
way doesn't mean that's not very nice at
some point I go it's best if we just go
to the room and try to find blow
as always you got rid of me I went to my
room the next morning I think I [ __ ]
you that night with bingo to be
continued the next like when a girl's
blackout on vodka that's what I really
[ __ ] make it happen yes do you think I
wasn't blacked out point being the next
morning shock raft cause did I make an
[ __ ] out of myself with that
Mallory girl from family ties I go you
are [ __ ] yelling you don't know what
love really means and then you were
crawling on all fours eating their
leftover pizza off the floor
and without any kind of irony she goes I
ate pizza I'm not supposed to have carbs
meeting someone for years right yeah
that's when you were just in your first
early stages she was eating disorder oh
[ __ ] yeah no she was like gosh anorexic
so double whammy she would understand
the yeah yeah joke where I'll [ __ ] I ate
carbs oh my god 52 ounces of vodka oh my
god a crust like the beat before I even
said that was like please tell me to
just say the pepperoni close plug the
head bird thing yeah you have a box set
of I have a vinyl box set of mature
berg's albums and then I wrote a book
and there's a USB and then other stuff
but where did they find a girl in chakra
RV find the lost RV we went up to crash
some traction like I tried like I can't
even think about what was in that van as
it went into the clump like it could
have been mrs. uterus in there or
something I don't know DNA anyway where
do you fires mega Hedberg to come is
there a website they people can find
Mitch Hedberg at well there's Mitch ever
got that but like it'll be on the scene
you'll just know it's like yes hugely
and I've been saying like Vice magazine
came up to do an interview because
there's do it they are picking comedy
and doing a series rather than whichever
Doug Sandom how Amy Schumer Mitch
Hedberg is called I don't know they're
picking us something far away at your
Twitter each Eleanor Jake area bingo
Bingaman little chat Shawcross d fatty
shad Schenck first time in LA HD like
Harley Davidson fatty the chanc is my
real name is there a middle name Jason
Jason I just want to ask one question
we'll close it out what do you feel
about squatters when you were 20 what do
you think about squatters like I'm
squatting on your property and what do
you think of the mall now am i the
squatter do I own or you're reading an
article about squatters usually don't
have a lot of family so it's easy to
throw them in
Chuck him in a well when Rene and I
lived in Venice we uh I rented the place
next door was an office and I stopped in
once I rented it I stopped in on
Christmas and there were two homeless
people this is a known story if you know
me but anything look it is in the book
yeah good and they go oh sorry this
place has been empty forever I go well
you're grandfathered in just don't [ __ ]
on the doorstep Rogan was here he had to
go
no he came in he they used to come over
for cocktails that would be friend your
spotter and make it a good situation of
[ __ ] a juggie from the man show and
he brought her over for dinner so it was
me and the two homeless people
really yeah no these are homeless people
they live on my stoop next door but I
think you see that's who you are you
would incorporate it into a different
situation play I would [ __ ] kill
squatter well although five is a
squatter
I'd kill an owner so it's one of those
things I just seems like all with you on
that just seems like you're a killer and
I like that let me say that okay from
South Philly right and we had I don't
know if you remember this in the 80s
Frank Rizzo was our mayor and they had
these people they called him to move
people but they were basically the move
they would go on people on the top of
their row homes
yeah and just live there like just just
camp out where they were they on top of
people who are struggling origin
[ __ ] places North Philly
the area and but the mayor got pissed
because they couldn't get him out and I
remember the lady's name her name is
Ramona Africa because I was a kid when
the whole block on fire right and when I
was little my brother Billy used to put
like not inhale his cigarette and he
would blow the smoke in my hair so it
would kind of linger yeah and I would do
her as a character in front of my mom
but yes I bet the only ever squatter
I saw but I don't know I'm so conflicted
like if you're like spider-man --is--
and you can go up into a like top last
place and Dubai or [ __ ] London
depends on what your squatters can do
yeah if they go they have some talent I
mean Ramona we're all living in cities
the other human beings create it's a
little bit embarrassing to be like hey
I'm from late like you're living in
someone else's [ __ ] like how dare we
say that this is our place when like
people made up people created in
fantasize these cities way before we
came along I think she's over in tonight
helping everyone are you driving uber
I'll squat you can sleep with me and
bingo just back to Lake um about four
months ago Doug called me it's very rare
these days and I'm like hey Warren he
goes just listen to my podcast like it's
all I called you Oh
died you don't want to [ __ ] talk
about it over and over again
sweetie fair enough so did you listen to
the podcasts or did you just [ __ ]
well it goes minute seventeenth no
probably caught up in talking about it
too much I lost my best friend - so I
understand you break your arm and you
have a cast and the first person that
asks you go oh I get into a fight and
then the eighty eighty fifth person I'm
started talking about the [ __ ] cast
can I hide it I hear ya check it out but
what if I didn't know about the cast or
the fight or the lost friend I'm just
sitting in my house avoiding phone calls
and I'm like Doug finally answer and I
go how are you I feel guilty because I
kind of love my friend that passed was
Freddy Soto a very funny caller yo yo so
I kind of do that - Corey Soto - because
she just easily so I had to distance
myself much yes yeah and yeah so it's
like a weird and I was friends with and
every time we talked about it they got
married but smooth that genuine from the
beginning so I was like weird yeah so
yeah I get that I understand that you
don't want to talk about what every cast
is a legend here at The Comedy Store
because then she was a wrestler then she
was a comic then she toured with Dice
Clay yeah we're doing Vegas next weekend
so he's like [ __ ] he's crazy right
now yeah
is he being really funny now dice is
always funny no I know that no that's a
word without a doubt the worst being
ridiculously funny we did Opie and
Anthony at the same time and there's no
personality in comedy today or since
dice that I agree he just walked in and
owned the room oh yeah he was nice to me
I saw you especially you're [ __ ]
funny anyway who was [ __ ] I wish I
could be that guy I'm so polite
generally but in real life I'm so polite
III can't do I think every one of your
fans kind of know that which is this
like double layer of love something
about you being that are your fans wild
like his like like I love dice fans
they're the worst and best cuz as soon
as you come out especially as a woman
come out on stage they're like [ __ ]
show us your tits yeah they try to rape
you immediately but you gotta feel
they're not that bad but they are all on
the killer termites babe this is a
Comedy Store Provenza you're welcome to
come in Rick Ingram who is my co-host
cookie work here I mean used to perform
here all the time cuz I started here in
93 you were always here I wasn't always
here I remember he's very creepy here
for a long time when did you leave dead
years better never been down here before
any when Oh haunted down here this
before well the last time you performed
here that
hande different like you shut them
divide here's fantastic it's
unbelievable and I think most of it is
because we got rid of Tommy
unfortunately because I kind of hired by
the Topshop it'll make things great it's
a joke oh we used to we used to play
rock and roll places in LA yeah and then
wait the main room no one ever uses the
main room it's dead yeah Zoe's room and
now the main room is sold out [ __ ]
enemies and been great but but more so
than the shows just the vibe is great I
really like it's become like a great
place to hang absolutely
I used to feel like get the [ __ ] out if
you weren't like one of eight people
exactly a group of comics that were
doing that somewhat bullying people were
like if the Busboys didn't like God who
was on an earlier version because we're
gonna have to we've been doing this for
like two hours so yeah yeah it's like an
hour and I yeah three-part Comedy Store
that's all right I don't care I love it
this is like over a band well and that
was I'm saying that was misunderstood
because Rogen did the right thing he
called Mitzie immediately what he did he
called her she was fine with it but then
Tommy took it in his own hands and
changed up the subject Tommy in prison
or something cuz you're talking about
him like he's not gonna like get on why
don't you do the green room because
every comic it is the [ __ ] green room
why don't you do why don't you buy a
[ __ ] Network what do you mean a
network
this cost some money and we don't have
it and we need somebody to get behind it
and it's whatever old how much money
does this podcast cost with a GoPro
nothing yeah a little bit of money but
not I mean I could Rob 14 people loved
it
comedians love Jeremy in the background
you just need the [ __ ] good [ __ ] Ron
Jeremy's not where the money goes it
doesn't need to be over produced no
actually if you if I think about it for
one second in a drunk addled brain
that's a podcast with a camera that's
true GoFundMe well that's that's what I
was just about to say but the reason
that we could get so many really
interesting people how you know how he
get a Gary Shandling and how we can get
you know the group that was on I'll get
Gary Shandling it has to be a certain it
has to be something more than just a
podcast with cameras in order to look it
in a way that is the most interesting
you showed right but we just had in this
[ __ ] basement we just had a list
talent that's true yes we are we are
going down now yes because there's my
Brendon Walsh and Joe Rogan and Ricky
goes back yes I saw you last night for
the first time you're really funny
though because whatever Kunta Kinte was
here
he goes by Toby he learned his lesson
Showtime okay you know what I see it on
Provenza time Provenza Chanda Provenza
Network yeah but you know what it really
was probably good produce and everything
but it was a bunch of people that you
have the ability any time any day in the
best way it was great lady just stood up
in the main room during Anthony Jeselnik
said furious start screaming you're
offensive man if you'll sit back down
you will see how that taking his friend
for an abortion piece is funny come out
as a gazel hang tell tell tell the
Jeselnik piece or I wouldn't dance it's
the story it's the story of him taking a
friend of his to get an abortion yeah
good catch he's just working it out but
it's more it's there's so much going on
in that bits more than just funny long I
like to act like jazz elects the [ __ ]
waiter I'm like can you give me a beer
this one my fav yeah his last line is
she was walking out she just kept
screaming over and over how offensive he
is she's like I didn't come here to be
offended you know how offensive you are
where do you usually go to be offended
that's how I got rich was a straw for
that camel's back what ticked her off
she was there as her friend's birthday
party I would love to be offended I
can't imagine what it would take have
you ever been maybe a sinkhole well like
if I saw my friends go down a sinkhole
there's so offended I'm offended a
million times a day I'm just a whiny
[ __ ] about it but on page boring is the
only thing that offends a comedy show is
trite yes yeah but you know if it
weren't for people like that woman and
I'm not justifying her getting up and
ruining show or anything like that there
are people who feel like that then
because half of what's funny about it is
watching people you know trying just
filter these ideas like you know outside
of the cubicle somehow they they've gone
into a world where things aren't you
know corporatized it's because we are
over talking each other so yeah there
are listeners I hope yes but yes you're
absolutely right yeah I mean you were I
mean now you're your crowd is your crowd
but but I don't know I would never do a
show here I would never do a show here
cuz you think people would say it cuz
somebody did it's Rogan the other night
and all she was going with boo that
sinks and he was just comparing you know
men not being as good as a women not
being as good as men so I don't know why
they would boo I don't get it
we're a New Jersey stress factor stress
factory with dyes love that place was
opening for it's an awesome Club and the
dice crowd that came out they it
basically looked like it was 1989 John
Val be like they come from do they get
yet that it's an act no they still don't
know she's probably about fifty
literally stood up I'm sorry screaming
basically the same thing that that's so
rude and you're a misogynist these goes
what a misogynist do you think you're
coming to see that's why I don't I I
I've developed a niche death metal type
of niche audience
it is definitely your if you like music
you don't like death metal I'm a big
music fan well I don't like death metal
well I'm the death metal I have that
little kind of a little piece of the pie
and I plated them and I don't go outside
of my circle well he wasn't outside of a
circle it's and they program his fan
time to him I don't know anything called
a seance
yeah what about a comedy seances comedy
can we tell you we met Mitch in Florida
you tell the rest of that story please
Rick I was I was sitting at the bar and
the Coconut Grove improv with OJ Simpson
name dropper
probably 20s are talking about owed when
now Mitch now Mitch's murder has gotten
really mysterious
now it's compelling he stayed around to
watch dice because his mom was there
yeah yes so he walks up and we call him
culottes whatever fair enough
Capri his dice is burning his capri
pants pedal pushers and Miss Rhoda
update on its website before y'all y'all
even knew what y'all [ __ ] web sites
were he wrote that like it was so
exciting to see days yes Wow touching
words he did three updates on his
website ever he stunk at web sites he
walked up I remember his mom being there
and he was like hey we went to your show
and I was like oh that that's cool it's
Mitch Hedberg he probably didn't think
he even knew who it was
that's cool yeah I mean I think he was
fairly big at that point yes every open
mic her was basically doing a ripoff
yeah at that point yeah news I just
wanted to tell you good show and then he
looked over and [ __ ] oj oj oj he's
like hey oh my god i wanna call me so
bad I can yes are you friends of those
he's dead
and miss saw yeah I remember meeting his
mom mom see it's starting to get really
hey we saw you earlier today and I go
really
how did you know was me if you hadn't
seen me perform yet and he said so I saw
you and I said hey look at that guy
standing by himself in front of Hooters
doesn't he look really sad the way a cop
can profile a perpetrator
he's knock-kneed standing alone pacing
around in the back alley he must be my
opening act that Club done and stayed
longer to see dice and yeah oh my god I
can't believe you're here with OJ and
Mitch knew it my opening act
I had an uber driver who turns it turned
out to be on the bill with me I did Marc
Maron's podcast yesterday and then we
get it was very quick yeah the point I
don't think he likes alright seriously
loves you I don't know the point is he
hates everybody like I do but but we get
an uber driver at his house he goes is
this the house the president was at and
he's got a black suburban and he told us
his story about how he he had a call
that day and but they were waving people
away but they saw his black suburban and
assumed that he was Secret Service and
waved him up to Marc Maron's house and
then he rolled down the window and there
no no you have to go the other way okay
I don't have a lot of funny stories from
uber drivers but that was
all the kids are doing Ober bits it's
the news Eleanor did you know what you
bit off when you said hey let's go in
the basement idea but I'm enjoying it I
don't be rude but how many times ever
you heard I don't mean to be right Liam
time thank you my mom told me to see
your beautiful I'll talk to you later
you guys going upstairs properly hey
thank you for everyone that was on the
Comedy Store Twitter at [ __ ] there's a
lot of poo oh my god
yeah you should Brendon Walsh would run
another Panama I want to do another
Panamint just to get everyone back so we
can recreate the story so I can write
one book just about the death valley yes
because it comes up on the podcast
almost the only reason I go is the
overthrown
sure James Inman was the headliner when
I started open mikes and candy such an
incredibly insane human being but it's
so nice to me and then just immediately
just snap and start yelling yes become
advice that need to me they don't stop
playing 38 special on the [ __ ] radio
it was like a 19 year old kid born in 81
well one year Inman was voted king of
the party and then there was a violent
overthrow suitable skin on your cheeks
good night yeah this is this is the
first Comedy Store podcast from the
basement we've had a lot of great guests
and keep listening come to the Comedy
Store see a comedy show
Rick Ingram hello can we do this as a
swap cast you know that's great is that
we call it a swamp yes I've coined the
term swap cast if you have a podcast and
I have a podcast we both put it out so
there's no reason you you get my
listeners I get your list legally this
is a long [ __ ] swamp cast this is the
Doug Stanhope podcast this is the Comedy
Store podcast
there's no reason to bifurcate the
problem
you